what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar and i am back at it again to
discuss the latest
craziest developments in the one piece
story if you enjoy these one piece
chapter reviews and want to keep them
coming the best thing you can do is
smash that like button and share this
video
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell or you will miss future one piece
videos i set up a playlist of all of the
one piece videos i made so far about
yonko
warlord's worst generation and more so
feel free to check that out link in the
description
while you wait for the weekly chapters
to drop keep in mind there will be
spoilers in this video we are talking
about the latest chapter chapter 981
after all now without further ado let's
jump into it
so what an unbelievable chapter this is
we start out with luffy absolutely
dominating the cover of short and jump
this week
we also have a wano aka japanese
inspired background
including a samurai sword the famous
waves from the old japanese painting the
great wave of kanagawa
and a shenron looking dragon as well and
with this epic chapter one piece
definitely deserved to be highlighted on
the cover we also get a two-page colored
spread
of the straw hats partying with some
animals wearing shades
zorro straight up fell asleep while
sanji is the dj
this is sort of like a straw hat version
of what the beast pirates have been
doing
partying and drinking and i for one
would prefer having sanji rather than a
poo
as my dj any day of the week this
chapter is translated as
engagement and it is definitely engaging
aside from marriage connotations
engagement means an arrangement to do
something or go
somewhere at a fixed time and all these
guys definitely have a date with destiny
right now
if you'll remember last chapter kid got
an oh so satisfying hit on napu
apu was making trouble for luffy and
zorro and kid just wrecked him
apu was the one who sold him and by
extension killer out to kaido
so there was so much meaning behind that
giant metal arm hitting into the worst
generation musician
we're told that kid's strike breaks the
very stone emphasizing how strong it is
apoo looks awful his piano teeth are
smashed
but we can assume that our worst
generation pirate won't go down that
easily like when the yonko clash
worst generation clashes usually take
time just think about how luffy
and zoro had trouble with basil hawkins
earlier on in the water arc
still whatever happens that was one
satisfying hit although i have expected
the hot-headed kid
to just keep punching him into a pulp
right there however the slow beast
pirates start to come around
and figure out that kit is not one of
them he is
in actuality captain kit of the worst
generation
also some of you rightly pointed out
that i forgot to count
killer as part of the worst generation
pirates present in the last chapter
but there's no way you can miss him in
this chapter where he definitely gets to
play a bigger role
and we'll go over that in a bit counting
basil hawkins
apu drake killer kid law luffy and
zorro we at least have eight in the
general area
which is two-thirds of the supernova and
well over half of the entire worst
generation 13
which includes yonko blackbeard when you
think about it this is a truly
insane war that will significantly shape
the future of the one piece
world already we got at least half the
yonko
yonko commanders two thirds of the
supernova
and the most skilled samurai among
others not to mention we'll probably
have characters continue to show up
and drake brings in the connection with
the marines and their possible
involvement
this really feels like it's gonna be
bigger than marine ford right now
and there is no statement more hype for
a one-piece fan than that
but let's not get ahead of ourselves we
get another queen freaking out moment
and that's like his signature at this
point with his eyes popping out of his
face
in contrast to a more stoic king who i
like to think of as pterodactyl batman
queen's freak out is understandable
though imagine thinking your territory
is under control and then finding out
it's quite the opposite in the worst way
possible then we get kid coming out with
what he's been feeling
calling out the fact that apu's alliance
with him was just a ploy
he calls up who kaido's informant pretty
much his snitch
and nobody wants to be called a snitch
interestingly enough apou gets serious
and honest
he is usually a pretty comedic character
but here he straight up tells kid that
believing that their alliance
would allow them to take down a yonko
was ridiculous
he tells him to open up his eyes again
we see this gap forming between people
like luffy and kit who set no limits on
what's possible
and more quote unquote realistic people
like apu who can't even dream of beating
a yonko
and although it is crazy to think you
can beat a yonko it's also only those
people who have a shot at doing it
it's like that quote by steve jobs the
people who are crazy enough to think
they can change the world
are the ones who do end quote after all
you miss 100 of shots you don't take
and that's why it is clear that people
like kapu will never be the pirate king
while with people like kid luffy and
blackbeard you never know what can
happen
apu also tells kid that pirate alliances
don't have happy endings
here is another part of appu's world
view that's coming through
in his mind people will screw him over
if he doesn't screw them over
first in this world you shouldn't aim
too high and you can't trust people
in this way he's the opposite of luffy
who is convinced that he'll be the
pirate king
and who values his friends and alliances
as much as anything
we know that luffy wouldn't betray kid
but we do know that kid is paranoid
now because of what happened with apu
and that paranoia almost kept him from
joining luffy
my fear is that kid might let apoo get
to him and backstab
luffy because he fears luffy
backstabbing him first
i really hope that doesn't happen though
because i'm a big captain kid fan
and i hate to have to hate him i'm
hoping that a pool's words apply more so
to the big mom and kaido pirate alliance
which could in theory fall apart
just as quickly as it was cooked up
during a fight to the death
back to apu who hits kid with a fighting
music attack
the fact that kid gave him the chance to
also suggests to me that appu's words
were really getting to him and thus
distracting him
clearly despite our best wishes apu
still has some fighting music left in
him
despite the hit kid smiles and calls apu
garbage
which gives me hope although kid does
have much more of a bad boy reputation
when compared to luffy
it seems clear that he has his own code
of honor and that he equates betraying
your comrades
and being an informant with being
garbage queen then straight up gives
everyone permission to kill them
although kaido would want them to join
his crew
queen knows not to underestimate these
supernovas killer tells kid that they
have to go
being the cool head of reason to kids
hot-headedness just like old times
it's good to see that killer is back to
normal and he no longer seems like that
traumatized and lost
person he was for a while a giant
coconut head with shades attacks with
his huge spike club that seems to be
bigger than kid's whole body
this dude turns out to be hacha of the
numbers these guys are comparable to
giant in size and have horns they're
associated with the beast pirates yet
another part
of kaido's op crew to worry about
however this dude also shows that he has
a drinking problem and that he gets out
of control which seems to be a recurring
aspect of the beast pirates
as a whole the crew is probably made up
of the strongest individual
members but it's been emphasized that
there's a lack of control and loyalty
we saw with some of the flying six that
they are openly combative with the
all-stars
and want to take their positions we see
that kaido can't control his son
and we know that apu and hawkins appear
to be working with kaido because of fear
rather than friendship or true loyalty
this powerful crew
may well be destined to go down like the
rock's pirates
because they can't get along as a
unified whole with a common sense of
purpose
in the middle of the battlefield an
arrow is launched at kit and luffy kicks
it out of the way before it can hurt the
kid
he tells kid to go and then we get some
more of the hilarity that we got a taste
of last chapter
we see luffy blaming kid for messing
things up even though luffy was the one
to first blow their cover
zorro then points out that luffy's not
one to talk
and then kidd says the same about zorro
who recently cut down a building and
then blamed luffy for causing a scene
man these kinds of scenes really are
priceless then we have killer
just thinking about how ridiculous all
three of them are
again showing that he's back to being
the man of reason that he was before
it is killer who has somehow deduced
that apu's powers are not quite as op
as we thought it's not just the sound
waves from a pool's fighting music that
hurts you
you have to actually hear the music so
killer tells them to cover their ears
and the ear covering combined with the
distance they've reached is enough to
avoid damage from the annoyed apoo
killer seems to have built in protection
in his mask since we don't see him
covering his ears
what do you think of this uphoo nerf let
me know i personally feel like there had
to be some trick to it
otherwise he would be near unstoppable
especially if he kept on strengthening
his powers over the years
we may also get interesting implications
in the future because the straw hats and
their allies
might have to fight some future battles
without being able to hear
right away we get a funny scene where
killer explains that the attacks will
only reach them
if they can hear them and if they can
hear them then the attacks are
unavoidable
but of course the other 3 worst
generation pirates didn't hear a word
because they have their ears covered i
really love this about one piece
that even in super hype situations oda
has time to sprinkle in that humor
as our four supernovas run people get
excited by the amount of worst
generation pirates here
and how they could grow their own
reputations by taking them out
killer because of his failed smile is
called a pleasure by some of the
bystanders
and we find out that he ate it because
orochi told him that would give him a
chance to save his captain
and wow that just further increases my
respect for killer
kid and killer definitely have a great
friendship going on and they're both
clearly loyal af which is a good sign
while luffy tells kid once again not to
cause a scene
they are spotted by who's who from up
above he recognizes them as
udon escapees we were told recently that
the flying six were all
captains of crews and so it makes sense
that who's who
has his own crew that he leads the crew
wonders if they should go help with
escapees but who's who is more concerned
with finding kaido's son yamato
he knows that's the biggest win for him
and makes it clear that that's the
crew's first priority
he also mentions that he doesn't want to
lose to sasaki
so he clearly views him as his biggest
rival in the flying six
the theme for his own crew seems to be a
cross between batman with horns
and catwoman since there do seem to be
some nicely dressed and tailed cat girls
at who's whose side
and again potential problems and kaido's
crew are highlighted because instead of
wanting what's best for the crew
who's who seems more concerned with
beating sasuke
remember that sasuke and who's who are
both hoping to challenge an
all-star and queen mentioned that he'd
erase one of the flying six last chapter
now who's who seems to be responding to
that as he says that he
also wants to wipe somebody out clearly
this moment implies that they might have
beef with each other
although there's also the possibility
that they don't mean each other
specifically
it definitely would make sense to go
after jack in my view
if you had to fight an all-star because
he seems to be the weakest link at this
point
but if who's who is confident about
going after queen 2
that's just insane how strong he might
be and by extension the muscle power
that kaido has within his crew
would also be off the charts although
who's who may even want to use
queen if it gives him the opportunity to
get rid of his flying six rival
we then finally get to big mom who's
been changing for a while it feels like
there is some confusion here there's
mention of a ship with big mom's family
being in good shape they should arrive
soon but there's also mention
of it being strange that there's been no
sign at the appointed port
there's a conversation going on here but
we only see big mom is she talking to
someone or is she talking to herself and
the split personality that developed
when she lost her memories
is this another clue that she'll work
against kaido we'll have to wait and see
we jump to kinemon since it seems clear
that kaido doesn't know about their
plans
they'll change up their strategy a bit
rather than the whole force going to the
rear entrance
they'll split in two one group will take
a shortcut and pose as the enemy while
the other half of the pincer move goes
around
they hope to trap kaido and orochi like
that although even the idea of trying to
corner kaido sounds pretty crazy
unexpectedly they realize that the 2000
of them
will have to cross a bridge right next
to a brothel
the chance of not raising suspicion in
such a scenario
is pretty much zero while kinemon is
worried sanji is overjoyed
we find out that the sexy giant black
maria is the one who rules over the
brothel
which is an interesting development
hopefully we don't get in a situation
where sanji has to fight black maria
because that would definitely not turn
out well
as sanji is drawn magnetically to black
maria's domain
nami shinobu and karachon suggest that
they'll join him as a search team for
momonosuke
so kinemon doesn't have to worry about
him and he can focus on the battle ahead
of him we see how much kinemon's been
worrying about momonosuke
which is touching but a part of me
believes that momonosuke
will carry out his promise and find a
way to escape on his own
i feel like that will be an important
step for his development into a strong
leader
sanji comes out more depressed than
you've ever seen him and perhaps even
more depressed than you've ever seen
usopp the question in our minds is what
could possibly have happened to make
sanji so sad
he reveals that he wasn't able to find
any ladies
then in a hilarious stream of events we
figure out that luffy causing a scene
actually led to the brothel being
emptied out
so it worked out swimmingly this feels
like that will of the luck that seems to
be following luffy
things work out perfectly so that they
can cross the bridge
they split up as previously mentioned
then the team with kinemon and chopper
see that there is someone in one of the
windows
as big mom herself opens the window
everyone hides in time except of course
chopper who was pretty much an unwilling
friend to her when she lost her memories
he even told her her name was olin just
as a shocked chopper makes
eye contact with a mellow seeming big
mom we jump scenes again
now the question is is this gonna be a
huge hiccup
since one of the yonko discovered them
or is chopper going to be able to use
big mom or rather olin to their
advantage
perhaps some recurring head damage will
lead to some truly crazy
twists but we'll have to wait another
chapter at least to find out
but whatever happens it makes for a huge
cliffhanger we then jump to the upper
waterfall of wano and we see
charlotte perospero saying he won't
forget what king did
remember in what was one of the funniest
moments in one piece
king turned into his pterodactyl form
and knocked their ship down the
waterfall last time
so they couldn't make it to wano that's
when big mom fell off into the water and
lost her memories
while the rest of the family stayed on
the falling ship so this is take two and
pero sparrow is pretty confused
he says that an alliance with the beast
pirates is insane
and he's questioning what big mom is
thinking the idea of sanity is brought
up again and big mom's unstable mental
condition
definitely seems like it will be an
important variable during the rest of
the arc
we see other family members including
sweet commander charlotte smoothie
who seems on board with whatever big mom
decides
while the others emphasize that getting
payback on luffy is the big thing here
he insulted big mom's reputation and so
they gotta make him pay or the big mom
pirates seem weak
having a yonko's crew wanting to kill
you this badly is pretty crazy
and it shows how much of an impact
luffy's been able to make on this world
up until now then just as they're making
it to wano
pero sparrow remembers that it was
around this point
that king pushed him off the last time
he still clearly has ptsd
from the incident and it doesn't help
when he sees something in the air
could it be king again but no we turned
the page
and it's freaking marco the phoenix one
of the few
other flying zone users and former
numero uno commander
of the whitebeard pirates i gotta say
when i first saw him on the page
my heart literally felt like it skipped
a beat and all hype limiters were
smashed
this is huge but it doesn't stop there
exactly like
king marco knocks them off so they can't
make it to wano
will they even try a third time knowing
that they might just go through the same
humiliation again and again
worst case scenario marco has bought
significant time
and he suggests suggested that time will
be enough saying that the next time they
make it up
this age of ours might look a lot
different
meaning the big mom pirates will be too
late for the fight
we then see nekomamushi and izo both of
whom were former retainers for odin
and also served as members of the
whitebeard pirates especially ezo
who stayed and became the 16th division
commander
finally we have the successors of the
whitebeard pirates helping the
successors of odin's will
it would have been cool if whitebeard
helped odin fight kaido
but it's still very cool to see marco
and perhaps quite a bit more of the
former whitebeard pirates
here to help luffy and wano whitebeard
and luffy had a good relationship and
whitebeard wanted him protected as did
ace obviously
so it isn't a surprise that marco wants
to help luffy and having a yonko level
crew for allies
is beyond epic now obviously we don't
know how many people from the original
crew made it here after they lost to
blackbeard in the payback war
but nevertheless having someone like
marco enter the mix
is very significant in a few pages we
went from our boys taking on two yonko
and their crews
to only having to take on one crew and
having the help of marco and former
whitebeard pirates
this really changes everything about
this war and without her family there to
talk some sense into her we might be
seeing more of olin
and less of big mom things are finally
beginning to seem like they may not be
completely impossible for the straw hats
and that's saying a lot considering they
were planning on taking down two yonko
just a chapter ago
i really love this about shonen some
people might call this stuff
an unrealistically convenient turn of
events but i view it as the universe
rewarding luffy and the rest
for having the courage to try i feel
like in real life too once you commit to
a goal
you'll also get help from the universe
you didn't see coming
however when it comes to those who do
nothing because they've decided their
dreams are impossible
those people will obviously never
accomplish their dreams and might even
turn out like apu
and no one wants to turn out like a poo
and that is it for this
pretty long chapter review i'm surprised
by how long this one turned out but it
makes sense because there's so much to
cover
in this chapter it was absolutely crazy
with so many twists and turns
things are really speeding up now and i
think we'll be in the thick of it before
you know it
if you do enjoy these one-piece chapter
reviews and want to keep them coming the
best thing you can do is smash that like
button and share this video
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial ring that notification
bell or you will miss future one piece
videos
feel free to check out my one piece
playlist link in the description while
you wait for the next chapter to drop
and suggest
any one piece topics you'd like to see
covered in the comments
lastly the youtube ad rates have
significantly dropped recently so the
help and support we're getting from our
anime uproar patrons is now more
important than ever
a very special thank you goes out to our
patrons over on patreon who help us
survive these youtube issues and who
help make videos like this one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
legend acknowledged by lord tuigo
himself
efren a and the one-tier patrons the
ones who stand atop
all clans stephen and grotta alolan
attempt the world
steelers acquire respect pate hepa
jonathan king decide brandon of isles
papa smurf the school bus
emperor otaku and richie martinez and
our pro hero tier patrons the one and
only gilgamesh nothing but a fan jason
wilson king zeldris anatoly kozadski
angel cruz cricket xp joel stanton very
gucci alicia actor jessica kayla fond
hinokami and water bonnie parks zodiar12
rethu and aura tian huang cynical kraken
volga 77 and deadly saint thank you all
so much if you enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com
animeopro and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
only discord where we talk about anime
life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
animeoper link in the description if
you're interested
you can now join the youtube channel and
support more content that way if you
prefer
whichever way you choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see you
space cowboys
[Music]
you